are you sick of all the fees and the
hassle of having a checking account at a
big bank check out our sponsor current
using the link below I'll tell you more
about them at the end of the video one
of the stories that stands out in terms
of police brutality from the last week
or ten days of protests is the video of
75 year old Martin Gugino
being shoved on to the ground by two
Buffalo Police officers Buffalo New York
hitting his head so hard that he
actually started bleeding from his right
ear seemingly knocked unconscious when
it happened
the two officers involved in that
incident have been charged with
second-degree assault after they were
filmed
knocking Gugino over these two officers
are 39 year old Aaron tur Golf ski and
32 year old Robert McCabe they've both
pleaded not guilty and they've both been
suspended without pay and this incident
led to the resignations of dozens of
Buffalo police officers no no not
because they are protesting what these
two officers did because they are
defending what the two officers did in
shoving Martin Guji Guji no and now
Donald Trump is actually attacking wait
for it the 75 year old guy who was put
into critical condition
by the officers The Daily Beast reports
that as of Monday afternoon Gugino had
been upgraded from critical to serious
but stable and Donald Trump yesterday
spread a completely baseless conspiracy
theory that Gugino was some part of an
Tifa setup of the police officers a
planned provocation of some kind this is
something that's been alleged by Donald
Trump's latest favorite propaganda
outlet Oh a n Donald from tweeting
yesterday quote Buffalo protesters
shoved by police could be an anti fapri
vaca tour 75 year old Martin Gugino was
pushed away after appearing to scan
police communications in order to black
out their equipment Oh way n I watched
he
fell harder than was pushed was aiming
scanner could be a setup
now the a lot of the debate is over
whether this could be true rather than
the insanity of Donald Trump the
president even tweeting something like
this but just to do our thorough due
diligence here's the story Trump is
referring to from Oh a and take a look
and you'll be able to tell that Trump is
just completely uncritically falling for
obvious adjectives and ax take a look
new reports find a protester pushed by
Buffalo police was appearing to use
comment and Tifa tactics when America's
Christian Rose looks into the matter any
report finds the latest tensions of the
Buffalo Police Department's could be a
result of a false flag provocation by
far left group and so far so I'm cutting
the video there because will be
demonetised if we show the actual
footage of googy know being knocked down
but you get the idea of the story on Oh
a and so I need you to understand that
this is a completely baseless conspiracy
it was even suggested that Gugino
again came equipped with some kind of
fake blood dispenser and that what
appears to be Gugino bleeding from his
ear is actually not imagine how absurd
this is he was an anti philantropy lease
into pushing him so he could slam his
own head into the pavement and put
himself in the hospital for a week what
a big win for the protesters right now
in contrast Donald Trump is attacking an
elderly man who was assaulted by police
and yet he has said nothing about the
KKK member who drove into a crowd of
protesters a few days ago now you might
hear me say that and you might be
wondering KKK what are you talking about
David I didn't hear about that
and that's exactly part of the problem
you might not even have heard of this
story but in Hanover Virginia thirty
six-year-old Harry Rogers was arrested
after he drove his truck into a crowd of
protesters and it has now been admitted
that he is a known leader of the Ku Klux
Klan and a disseminator of what is
considered or called a confederate
ideology Trump has said nothing about
that but is defend
police in one of the most brutal
anecdotes of these protesters while
suggesting that the victim a 75 year old
peace activist might be an auntie FAP
Lant equipped with surreptitious police
monitoring technology so what I would
like to see Republicans come out and say
is not whether they believe Trump's
conspiracy theory the oen conspiracy
theory I would like them to come out and
say that merely getting involved in this
type of thing is an absolute atrocity
for a president to do because a lot of
the debate sadly is about whether Martin
Gugino might be a provocateur whether
Martin Gugino might have brought a fake
blood device of some kind the real issue
is that the president is even involved
in this absolute gutter trash and the
effect of all of this is that it just
continues to divide the country if Trump
can divide the country about such an
obvious clear-cut case of police
brutality by sowing doubt and
uncertainty by amplifying a story from
OAM he is preventing people from coming
together about anything like if people
can't come together about this incident
then the country can be divided about
almost anything and we have to remind
ourselves that this is the President of
the United States who is saying these
things and participating in this stuff
this is what we would normally expect to
see people like Alex Jones tweeting
about and it's the president who's
tweeting about it
how does he have millions tens of
millions of supporters still and at a
certain point you know I did the segment
a couple of maybe a year little more ago
called we have to accept that there's a
lot of stupid people in the segment
clearly resonated and did very very well
although some people took offense to it
we have to understand that this says
something really horrifying about our
country that Donald Trump can be saying
these things and doing these things and
maintaining the support of tens of
millions of people
despite tweeting such obvious adjectives
we're going to continue following this
on the David Pakman show Instagram page
which is david pakman show on instagram
also follow me on
Instagram at David Pakman I think
tomorrow or the next day we're gonna
have a video of me harvesting my one
strawberry from my garden and a single
leaf of mint and eating it preparing it
in a gourmet fashion that's on my
personal Instagram David Pakman follow
the show on Instagram for more on this
story at David Pakman show we often talk
about the many different ways that big
banks take advantage of their customers
and one of our sponsors today is current
which is an online bank for those of us
who were sick of dealing with all of the
fees and the nonsense from the big banks
I use current myself if you're watching
this on YouTube here's my actual current
debit card that I'm holding up no
minimum balance they have 24/7 support
no overdraft fees up to $100 and it
won't get declined no ATM fees you can
use over fifty five thousand ATMs
nationwide and unlike other banks you
receive your direct deposits instantly
which means you'll get paid by your
employer up to two days sooner you can
deposit checks instantly using your
camera phone and unlike other banks
current instantly refunds the hold on
your card from pumping gas you can pause
your debit card instantly also really
useful in many situations there are just
so many different advantages to ditching
the big banks and instead use a bank
that puts their members first it takes
two minutes to sign up they'll
immediately ship you your debit card for
free go ahead and get started by
clicking the link down below the video